tomemos la función fx igual
a la x para darnos una idea de cómo se
ve la función hagamos un esbozo de esta
función la gráfica de la función se va a
ver algo así se va a ver algo así así es
que esta es
a la equis y lo que voy a hacer es
aproximar la función a la equis por
medio de una expansión de serie de
taylor o una aproximación de series de
taylor y lo voy a hacer no alrededor de
x igual a 0 sino alrededor de x igual a
3 por tomar un valor arbitrario entonces
este es x igual a 3 y aquí tenemos la
función que es f de 3 que es que a la 3
y al cubo entonces cuando nosotros
hacemos una aproximación por serie de
taylor la mejor aproximación de orden
cero es la función constante a la tres
una línea recta que pasa por ea la tres
si hacemos ahora una aproximación de
orden uno será un polinomio de primer
grado que en este caso corresponde a la
recta tangente a medida que agregamos
más términos esperaremos que éstos se
ajusten más al contorno de la función
converjan a la función posteriormente
hablaremos de convergencia y que también
se da esta convergencia
ahora desarrollaremos la serie de taylor
para esta función con la fórmula que
desarrollamos de manera intuitiva en el
último vídeo empecemos entonces con el
término de primer orden
tenemos que fx es igual a fcc
y en este caso es igual a 3
entonces fx efe de 3 es igual a 3
más efe prima en c efe prima de x es
igual ayala x es de las cosas
extraordinarias de ésta funcione al aek
es que si toma la derivada f prima de x
ésta coincide con ea la x de hecho
coincide con la enésima derivada de f
al continuar derivando ya la x siempre
tienes a la x si efe prima de x evaluada
en 3 nos da a la 3 por x menos 36 3 más
efe mi prima en c efe mi primer se es de
nueva cuenta ya la 3 entre 2 factorial
por x menos 3 al cuadrado
y continuamos más efe mi prima que
también es el x evaluada en c ese estrés
es a la 3 sobre 3 factorial por x menos
3 al cubo y así sucesivamente lo que es
más interesante más que seguir agregando
términos es ver qué sucede conforme
estos términos se van agregando ver como
al día agregando términos la
aproximación es mejor inclusive para
valores alejados de x igual a 3 para
visualizar esto utilicé wolframalpha
wolframalpha está disponible en
wolframalpha puntocom y le teclea algo
así como series de taylor para la x en x
igual a 3 esto fue lo que resultó de
hecho también pone la expansión aquí
esta expansión es lo mismo que nosotros
desarrollamos aquí ya la 3 más ya la 3 x
x 3 aquí lo tiene también wolframalpha a
la 3 más a la 3 por x menos 3 más un
medio de la 3 por x menos 3 al cuadrado
de hecho también desarrollan los
factoriales desde 3 factorial pusieron 6
y así
con el resto de los términos por acá lo
que es más interesante es que de hecho
se grafican los polinomios con cada vez
más y más términos
aquí tenemos en naranja la función f x
igual a ya la equis y luego nos indica
la aproximación de orden n se muestra
con n puntos así que la aproximación de
orden 1 donde tenemos un polinomio de
primer grado serían estos términos estos
dos términos que tenemos aquí arriba
aquí tenemos el término ya la 3 y el
término de la 3 x x 3 x t elevado a la
primera potencia así es que si sólo
fuéramos a graficar estos dos términos
lo tendríamos aquí con un punto es esta
línea recta la recta tangente en x igual
a 3 esta es la recta tangente en x igual
a 3 que es la aproximación de orden 1 ss
x igual a 3 y esa es la línea tangente
ahora si agregamos un término si tenemos
un polinomio de orden 2 aquí tenemos un
polinomio orden 2 porque tenemos un
término cuadráticas y expandimos este
término tenemos x al cuadrado lo que nos
da un polinomio de orden 2
busquemos ahora la curva que tiene dos
puntos la el polinomio orden 2 es la
curva que tiene dos puntos lo ubicamos
aquí aquí tenemos la curva con 12 puntos
aquí viene la curva que está entrando
pasa por el valor de x 3 de hecho es una
parábola y nota como hace un mejor
trabajo de aproximación a la función a
la x sobre todo acerca de x igual a 3 se
queda sobre la curva un poquito más
agregamos otro término déjame usar otro
color que he usado para indicar el otro
término que estamos agregando agregamos
otro término aquí tenemos un polinomio
de orden 3 veamos la gráfica del
polinomio de orden 3 la buscamos aquí la
tenemos 123 puntos es esta gráfica entra
por aquí desde la gráfica del polígono
de orden 3 y noten que entra un poquito
antes
pasa por la función en x 3 y sale por
aquí y nota cómo se queda un poquito más
y aquí sale la función agregamos otro
término tenemos ahora un polinomio de
orden 4
aquí tenemos estos cuatro términos aquí
está la curva entra por aquí nota que
entre un poquito antes sale un poco
después y observamos que cada vez que
agregamos un término la aproximación es
mejor para valores cada vez más alejados
de x igual a 3 agregando otro término
obtenemos esta de aquí espero que esto
te haya convencido de que entre más
términos agregamos mejor es la
aproximación imagínate entonces cómo es
la aproximación si nos acercamos a
agregar un número infinito de términos